1102 2103 2104 et 1125 2005 6 des
naissances est de mr olivier d'agay
aujourd'hui je suis prof je sens bon je
suis beau et intelligent
j'ai envie qu'on passe tant de
compliments 8
ils sont d'ailleurs gelé mérite bien on
qui pourrait se voir à julie elle va
être émerveillé on me voyait soudain 4,5
jeudi 26 de l'instant 27 salles est à
dire jusqu 8129 2130 julie regarde moi
c'est moi casimir
il me dit rien dit mais qu'est ce que tu
voudrais que je te dise
de toute façon j'ai pas le temps il faut
que je fini de compter mais caramel
alors d'autres me sens en sang
ça y est j'ai oublié va falloir que je
recommence françois oui ah bonjour
casimir body dont le moral a l'air bon
oui mais françois oui mais en fait ils
m'ont dit rien que faut-il te dire
qu'ils y me regarde moi je suis beau
intelligent je sens bon au bas du dos tu
es surtout très vaniteux et puis avec
tout le bien qu'ils pensent de toi
si en plus on ne faisait des compliments
ta tête gonflerait un conte fleuret
gonflera gaza je vais avoir mal on
inquiète pas va casimir elle va pas
éclater mais tu dois comprendre qu'on
veut pas passer notre temps de faire des
compliments ou bonbons halal et les murs
sont pas tristes et puis tu sais les
compliments sans arrêt c'est tout juste
bon pour les statuts les statuts
[Musique]
au
c'est parfait julie n'est pas dans son
kiosque
françois n'est pas là non plus ça me
donne juste le temps de m'installer très
bien ras françois a dit qu'on veut faire
des compliments qu'on statue alors on va
voir ce qu'on va voir
attention je passais par là
voilà là ce serait très bien ici là la
voilà oh que c'est beau statut de
casimir c'est émouvant de contempler le
socle de sa propre statue rouge
j'aimerais vraiment pouvoir me faire des
compliments en statue je vais être au
beau bien dépêchons-nous avant que
quelqu'un arrive hein les enfants vont
éviter rbds et aussi gilles françois il
faut que vous m'aidiez à trouver une
position de statut vous voulez bien
oui oui mais parlez pas trop fort parce
que c'est un secret alors montrez moi
les positions 1 comme ça aussi c'est pas
mal peut-être oui vous avez d'autres
idées à comme ça c'est bien oui
attendaient enfin à huy en tir à l'arc
peut être attend dé voir et ça vous
aimez ouais ya ça aussi peut-être au
west
voilà c'est bien entendu vous trouvez
vous vite sauvé vous vite
il s'agit de ne plus bouger
déraper restera mis au qu'est ce que
c'est que cette horreur statut de
casimir là elle est plutôt ressemblante
oui malheureusement on aurait pu au
moins lui affiner la taille de faire les
yeux - globuleux et là pour moi orages
aura été beaucoup moins mais pourquoi
avoir fait la statue de casimir mais
c'est vrai car il n'est pas mort que je
sache peut-être at-il quitté pour
toujours l'île aux enfants sont mes
tâches et ben ça serait une excellente
nouvelle
on veut débarrasser de ce grand lourdes
ou quoi cette statue me paraît un peu
trop vivante je crée une colère terrible
pour trouver quelque chose
j'ai une idée je devais vraiment dommage
c'est que cette statue ne puisse pas
danser ou chanter on est une très bonne
idée me suis dit stop très bonne idée
lorsqu'on voyait casimir chanter et
danser tout le monde avait envie de lui
faire des compliments que certains il
faisait preuve de tellement de grâce
qu'il était tout à fait admirable c'est
vrai ainsi ma statue si la statue de
casimir chantaient et dansaient qu vous
vous l'admirant riez c'est certain - bon
alors musica
[Musique]
avec ta chanson est un peu d'imagination
je vous en mets dedans pour tree hill au
sommet du bonheur tranquille
meurtri
ne soyez pas terrorisé je suis le monde
ribéry
je m'appelle casini
ce qu'est la belle couleur orange je
suis aussi donc un an
moi je sais jouer de la musique
je suis gay smalling amis si j'aime la
glace aux anchois
c'est pourquoi c'est mon droit avec une
chanson
un peu d'imagination
je vous emmène dans notre idée du
bonheur tranquille
c'est les couleurs incompris
un soyez pas terrorisé
je suis le monstre qui fait rire
je m'appelle casimir j'ai eu une marque
maggi rennes ni déborde askin je mange
l'oubli bullguard mais je n'en sors ma
[Musique]
campagne j'ai mis le nil de cocagne e6
mais même au 4e droit c'est mon droit
hongrois a vécu deux chansons
[Musique]
à
imagina
mais dans d'autres ici l'homme
du bonheur
découverte
ne soyez pas terrorisé
je suis le bon sens me fait rire
je m'appelle quasi mai
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]